françois fillon dans votre introduction
tout à l'heure au début du débat vous
avais dit le mot honnêteté on va le
prendre au sens large
je voudrais évoquer avec vous le livre
de nos confrères du monde fabrice lhomme
et gérard davet
dans ce livre françois hollande confirme
qu'à deux reprises
vous avez demandé au secrétaire général
de l'elysée jean pierre jouyet
d'accélérer les procédures judiciaires
visant nicolas sarkozy alors c'est très
précis dans cet ouvrage vous auriez dit
je cite
mais comment ça se fait que vous ne
puissiez pas la justice en faire
davantage
point de fin de citation c'est ça
l'exemplarité
j'ai déjà eu l'occasion de le dire
monsieur jouyet est un menteur abonnés
mois mais la ville et françois hollande
j'ai eu à y venir si vous me laissez
continuez monsieur juillet est un
menteur et je découvre que le président
de la république française non seulement
est inefficace et incompétent mais c'est
en plus un manipulateur et moi j'ai
honte j'ai honte pour mon pays de voir
que le président de la république
française se prête à des accusations
aussi médiocre
quant aux deux journalistes dont vous
venez parler je considère que pour avoir
débattu avec eux dans un prétoire
il manque pour le moins de déontologie
vous avez porté plainte contre
absolument est d'ailleurs le tribunal a
reconnu que j'avais été diffamé vous
allez à nouveau les poursuivre parce
qu'ils viennent d'écrire un livre paru
aujourd'hui je vais pas leur faire cet
honneur je vais pas leur faire cet
honneur mais croyez-moi quand on voit ce
qu'ils ont écrit et la situation dans
laquelle se trouve aujourd'hui le chef
de l'état
franchement on a honte pour les
institutions et on se demande comment ce
pays peut selon vous n'avez jamais
prononcé fait leur album jamais